This is an interesting vignette, because it's
kind of shocking to ask, but of course probably
some students playing with designs.
But the fellow said he walked into a room
one day, and there's a scale model of the
whole of Cambridge.
And it's very plain that all the pieces of
wood that were red were owned by Harvard,
and the ones that were blue were owned by
MIT.
And he says "Bill, there's a dotted line running
down the middle of Prospect Street and River
Street -- red on one side and blue on the
other."
And so, it's like, they're planning to divide
the whole city up!
But it was probably some design school student
doing his project.
But still, it's the kind of thing that people
always think.
People are always accused of being paranoid
about the power of these institutions, but
you know, there's hardly ... I could probably
count on the fingers of one hand the number
of businesses in Central Square that are still
here that were there when I came.
And all the factories and businesses that
were here, they're all gone.
But Harvard and MIT are still here, and still
growing.
No matter who runs them or who comes and goes,
the institutions live on -- like the Commonwealth
lives on, we pass as shadows.
A bad old joke I used to use often, "if it
weren't for Harvard and MIT, Cambridge would
just be another older, urban, northeastern
city on a river."
It's clear that MIT and Harvard's presence
have enormous impacts on the city -- positive
impacts.
There are very few negatives.
Are there demands on the housing market by
some of the graduate students?
Yes, but that's going to happen in any college
town.
If you're going to be a college town and deal
with that issue, let the colleges be Harvard
and MIT.
Cambridge is Cambridge in good part because
of institutions like MIT and Harvard.
And one hundred years of MIT, obviously just
look at Kendall Square.
Kendall Square has grown because of the MIT
connection and influence.
It has grown in a big way, it has provided
jobs, it's provided great financial resources
to the community.
It's provided quality construction.
It's now addressing issues that are at the
heart of a lot of neighborhood concerns.
So, I think it's provided educational opportunities
for people all around the world, as well as
many Cambridge residents.
It's a center of research, it's a center of
ideas.
Cambridge wouldn't be Cambridge without an
MIT.
I'm not saying that in any way other than
to say that's the truth.
That we are lucky as a community to have MIT,
and I think MIT is lucky as an institution
to be situated in a city like Cambridge that
thinks about the management of its city and
the welfare of its residents in a way that
will challenge the university.